Congressman John Lewis is a champion of
the civil rights movement and one of its
leading figures he marched alongside dr.
Martin Luther King jr. and was
repeatedly beaten and arrested during
nonviolent protest for racial equality
he was only 23 years old at the time
Lewis was the youngest person to speak
of the 1963 march on Washington from the
steps of the Lincoln Memorial Boy
congressman Lewis joins us now for his
first Network TV interview since the
protests over the death of George Floyd
began Congressman John Lewis it's so
good to see you I can't tell you you are
such a saw such a sight for sore eyes
today it's really good to see you I want
to start with getting your thoughts
about George Floyd the way he died your
reaction to that
and also your reaction to the news that
we had yesterday that all four officers
have been charged the way this young man
died watching the video it it made me so
sad it was so painful
it made me cry I kept saying to myself
how many more high many more young black
men would be murdered that the madness
must stop and it was very moving very
moving to see hundreds and thousands of
people from all over America and around
the world takes to the streets to speak
up to speak out to get in what I call
good travel or to get in the way and
because of the action
of young and old like white Latino Asian
American and Native America because
people cried and prayed people would
never ever forget what happened and how
it happened and it's my hope that we are
on our way to greater change to respect
the dignity and the worth of every human
being and it doesn't matter the color or
the background of whether they're male
or female he is straight we come to that
point and said we want people we one
family we all live in the same house not
just American house but the world house
I wanted to talk about the the protest
in particular because people were saying
it's a turning point it's a tipping
point yesterday Bishop TD jakes said
it's a turning point when you look at
the diversity of the crowd so I want to
know I know you've been watching I
understand you were moved to tears over
the weekend looking at the protest does
this feel and look different to you this
feel and look so different it is so much
more massive and all-inclusive to see
people from all over the world taken to
the streets to the roadways to stand up
to speak up to speak out I have to do
what I call getting in trouble and with
the since the determination and
commitment and dedication there would be
no turning back
people not understand what the struggle
was all about there's another step down
a very very long road to it
freedom justice
all humankind what would you tell
congressman young people and people
quite frankly who were not so young
about the best way to seek justice you
know there's been a lot of controversy a
lot of talk about the looting and we
should we should stress that most of the
protests were very peaceful but there
was some looting there was some
disruption what would you say to people
about the best way to achieve justice
well during the sixties the great
majority of us accepted a way of peace
the way of love the philosophy and
discipline or non-violence as a way of
life as the way they're living there's
something cleansing something wholesome
about being peaceful and orderly to
stand up and with a sense of dignity and
a sense of pride and never hate that dr.
King said over and over again hate is
too heavy a burden to bear the way of
love so much better way and that's what
we did we were arrested we were Jail we
would beat him but we didn't hate and we
have changed America and I was truly
believe what has taking place now and
will continue to take place to the next
few days and weeks is going to take us
much farther down that road to society
at peace with yourself people who know
you well congressmen say that you still
remain very optimistic and I'm wondering
how you're able to still be so hopeful
based on all that you've experienced
both physically and emotionally how do
you do that because as you said you were
beaten yes I was beaten left bloody and
unconscious well
never became bitter or hostile never
gave up
I believe that somehow in some way if
become necessary to use our bodies to
have redeem the soul of a nation then we
must do it create a society at peace
with herself and lay down the burden of
hate and division dr. King was there
violence and evil it must stop someplace
along the way and we became disciples of
the movement the ciphers of mourneth
akane showing you another great teacher
to do what we could to leave our society
better than we found it you know
President Trump is threatening Millard
military intervention to suppress some
of the protests what do you think about
that I think it would be a serious
mistake on the part of President Trump
to use the military to stop orderly
peaceful nonviolent protests you cannot
stop can I stop to call the history you
may use troopers you may use fire hoses
and water but it cannot be stopped
it cannot be any turning back we come
too far make too much progress to stop
not to go back the world is the input is
happening we are ready to continue to
move forward and what do you think is a
role of people who are not black who
want to support the movement we're
hearing a lot about that well we all are
human we all applauded a human family
and it doesn't matter whether you're
black a white Latino Asian American a
Native American we one people we one
family we all live in the same house to
war a house and as dr. King said again
we must learn to live together as
brothers and sisters if not we will
perish as fool's and I think what been
going on the past few days is living
truth that we're all connected and
nothing not anything going to separate
us congressman I have to ask you about
your health you know you had many people
worried you were diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer and you've been
getting treatment and so I want to know
how you're doing I also heard that for
the first time you got to see your cat's
you've been being treated in DC you got
to see the cat's over the weekend so I
want to know how you're doing what are
your cats names and why they give you
such comfort how's your hell start with
that well my health is improving I have
wonderful doctor and nurse anybody
taking good care of me I'm very hopeful
and very optimistic they're trying to
get me to eat more and I'm trying to eat
yes please do regain my weight my cats
names I call well we don't we call him
kitty kitty cat and they know each other
but when I went back home this past
weekend yeah there was some point
disappointed I don't think they
recognize me all right all right
congressman Lewis thank you so much
thank you for rolling with the punches
this morning you look great and I agree
you can eat a little more but you look
great we are so happy to have you here
this morning we'll be right back